when I was in the fifth grade I bought
an issue of DC Comics presents number 57
off of a spinarak on my local bookstore
and that comic book changed my life
the combination of words and pictures
did something inside my head that had
never been done before and I immediately
fell in love with the medium of comics I
became a voracious comic book reader but
I never brought him to school
instinctively I knew that comic books
didn't belong in the classroom my
parents definitely were not fans and I
was certain that my teachers wouldn't be
either
after all they never used them to teach
comic books and graphic novels were
never allowed during silence sustained
reading and they were never sold at our
annual book fair even so I kept reading
comics and I even started making them
eventually I became a published
cartoonist writing and drawing comic
books for a living I also became a high
school teacher this is why I taught
Bishop O'Dowd High School in Oakland
California I taught a little bit of math
and a little bit of art but mostly
computer science and I was there for 17
years when I was a brand new teacher
I tried bringing comic books into my
classroom I remember telling my students
on the first day of every class that I
was also a cartoonist it wasn't so much
that I was planning to teach them with
comics it was more that I was hoping
comics would make them think that I was
cool I was wrong this is the 90s so
comic books didn't have the cultural
cachet that they do today my students
didn't think I was cool they thought I
was kind of a dork and even worse when
stuff got hard in my class they would
use comic books as a way of distracting
me they would raise their hands and ask
me questions like mr. yang who do you
think would win in a fight Superman or
the Hulk I very quickly realized I had
to keep my teaching and my cartooning
separate it's
like my instincts in fifth grade were
correct comic books didn't belong in the
classroom but again I was wrong a fear
is into my teaching career I learned
firsthand the educational potential of
comics one semester I was asked a sub
for this algebra 2 class I was asked a
long-term sub it and I said yes but
there was a problem at the time I was
also the school's educational
technologist which meant every couple of
weeks I had to miss one or two periods
of this algebra 2 class because I was in
another classroom helping another
teacher with a computer related activity
for these algebra 2 students that was
terrible I mean having a long term sub
is bad enough but having a sub for your
sub that's the worst in an effort to
provide some sort of consistency for my
students I began videotaping myself
giving lectures I then give these videos
to my sub to play for my students I
tried to make these videos as engaging
as possible I've included these little
special effects for instance after I
finished a problem on the board I'd clap
my hands and the board would magically
erase I thought it was pretty awesome
I was pretty certain that my students
would love it but I was wrong
these video lectures were a disaster I
had students coming up to me and saying
things like mr. yang we thought you were
boring in person but on video you are
just unbearable so as a desperate second
attempt I began drawing these lectures
as comics I do these very quickly with
very little planning I just take a
sharpie draw one panel after the other
figuring out what I wanted to say as I
went these comics lectures would come
out to anywhere between four and six
pages long at Xerox these give them to
my sub to hand to my students and much
to my surprise these comics lectures
were a hit my students would ask me to
make these for them even when I could be
there in person it was like they liked
cartoon me more than actual me this
surprised me because my students are
part of a generation that was raised on
screens so I thought for sure they would
like learning from a screen better than
learning from a page but when I talked
to my students about why they liked
these comics lectures so much I began to
understand the educational potential of
comics first unlike their math textbooks
these comics lectures taught visually
our students grow up in a visual culture
so they're used to taking in information
that way but unlike other visual
narrative like film or television or
animation or video comics are what I
call permanent in a comic past present
and future all sit side by side on the
same page this means that the rate of
information flow is firmly in the hands
of the reader when my students didn't
understand something in my comics
lecturer they could just reread that
passage as quickly or slowly as they
needed it was like I was giving them a
remote control over the information the
same was not true of my video lectures
and it wasn't even true of my in-person
lectures when I speak I deliver the
information as quickly or slowly as I
want so for certain students and certain
kinds of information
these two aspects of the comics medium
it's visual nature and its permanence
make it an incredibly powerful
educational tool when I was teaching
this out of a 2 class I was also working
on my masters in education at Cal State
East Bay and I was so intrigued by this
experience that I had with these comics
lectures that I decided to focus my
final master's project on comics I
wanted to figure out why American
educators has historically been so
reluctant to use comic books in their
classrooms here's what I discovered
comic books first became a mass medium
in the 1940s with millions of copies
selling every month and educators back
then took notice a lot of innovative
teachers began bringing comics into
their classrooms to experiment in 1944
the Journal of educational sociology
even devoted an entire issue to this
topic things seemed to be progressing
teachers were starting to figure things
out but then along comes this guy this
is child psychologist dr. Frederic
wertham and in 1954 he wrote a book
called seduction of the innocent where
he argues that comic books cause
juvenile delinquency he was wrong now
dr. wertham was actually a pretty decent
guy he spent most of his career working
with juvenile delinquents and in his
work he noticed that most of his clients
read comic books what dr. wertham failed
to realize was in the 1940s and 50s
almost every kid in America read comic
books dr. wertham does a pretty dubious
job of proving his case but his book
does inspire the Senate of the United
States to hold a series of hearings to
see if in fact comic books caused
juvenile delinquency these hearings
lasted for almost two months
they ended in conclusively but not
before doing tremendous damage to the
reputation of comic books in the eyes of
the American public after this
respectable American educators all
backed away and they stayed away for
decades it wasn't until the 1970s that a
few brave souls started making their way
back in and it
really wasn't until pretty recently
maybe the last decade or so the comics
have seen more widespread acceptance
among American educators comic books and
graphic novels are now finally making
their way back into American classrooms
and this is even happening at Bishop
O'Dowd where I used to teach mr. Smith
one of my former colleagues uses Scott
McCloud's understanding comics in his
literature and film class because that
book gives his students the language
with which to discuss the relationship
between words and images mr. burns
assigns the comics essay to his students
every year by asking his students to
process a prose novel using images mr.
burns asked them to think deeply not
just about the story but also about how
that story is told and Miss maroc uses
my own american-born Chinese with her
English one students for her graphic
novels are a great way of fulfilling a
Common Core standard the standard states
that students ought to be able to
analyze how visual elements contribute
to the meaning tone and beauty of a text
over in the library miss counts has
built a pretty impressive graphic novel
collection Forbush bow down now miss
counts and all of her librarian
colleagues have really been at the
forefront of comics advocacy really
since the early 80s when a school
library journal article stated that the
mere presence of graphic novels in the
library increased usage by about 80% and
increased the circulation of non comics
material by about 30 percent inspired by
this renewed interest from American
educators American cartoonists are now
producing more explicitly educational
content for the k-12 market than ever
before a lot of this is directed at
language arts but more more comics and
graphic novels are starting to tackle
math and science topics stem comics
graphic novels really are like this
uncharted territory ready to be explored
America is finally waking up to the fact
that comic books do not cause juvenile
delinquency that they really do belong
in every educators toolkit
there's no good reason to keep comic
books and graphic novels out of k-12
education they teach visually they give
our students that remote control the
educational potential is there just
waiting to be tapped by creative people
like you thank you
[Applause]